[Music]
in attention-seeker news submitted by
takis our life mmm yeah I don't agree
with that fun yeah have you had it with
hooked up with like the [ __ ] cream
cheese and [ __ ] like that
Oh sounds pretty good that's in 7-eleven
[ __ ] where you like nacho cheese on it
and stuff this is some [ __ ] hood
snacks a waiter admits to lying about a
racist comment left on a receipt people
do that why why did you do that what did
he get out of it and why to post on
social media right yeah I think you just
wanted attention so the waiter wrote
something racist himself yes I heard
this has been happening these days where
people are manufacturing racism and in
becoming a victim and [ __ ] and that
that's [ __ ] up isn't it like that
other time where that guy said he got
like beat up or whatever in a parking
lot he just punched himself in the face
and then like took a picture of it like
oh it was a race race attack yeah fine
so this dude this 20 year old we're from
Texas named Khalil he posted this he's a
dope ass no this receipt it says we
don't tip terrorists and then he's
circled the name and then wrote that's a
cute way to write a mean nope oh yeah do
you want to read his yeah last night at
work I received this note from one of my
tables at the moment I didn't know what
to think nor nor you're already lying no
he says no nor [ __ ] what to say I was
sick to my stomach I share this because
I want people to understand that this
racism and this hatred still exists
although this is nothing new it is still
something that will test your faith all
day I've had to remind myself that Jesus
died for these people to know I've
decided to let this encourage me and
fuel me to change the world the only way
I know how
with tips no it's so - so to all the
haters out there keep talking you're
only helping me step into my destiny oh
god dude get the [ __ ] out of here so she
sir he was salty about not getting a tip
so he like left some racist [ __ ] on it I
mean yeah
what responsibilities maybe maybe they
left the tip in cash oh maybe that that
even looks like a fake receipt like he
just punched in some random order just
like oh right that hole no it really was
a customer and the this restaurants so
it's a it's called fault grass
steakhouse sounds delicious
so this place they they only employ
terrorists so they contacted the
customer how downloader you can banned
the customer from the restaurant so
initially when the story came out it
went viral
he even got interviewed by a news
station which I'm gonna show you his
interview in a second and is that way
far the further that he thought he's
like oh [ __ ] I don't know what to do but
you got a double down now there's a 2 DP
TV he had the one green I just wanted to
impress that one girl or whatever it was
let's get those legs man she likes so
then like this restaurant they ended up
saying that after further investigation
they learned that their employee
fabricated the entire story good on them
and then he ends up saying I did write
it I don't know I don't have an
explanation I mean yeah you do there is
no excuse for what I did
his explanation is only [ __ ] I wanted
attention yeah I wanted to be a victim
it's [ __ ] stupid and then this is the
this is the interview that's funny that
he packed under pressure
what there is terrorist he looks black
he looks like Trevor Noah what the [ __ ]
yeah what is he talking about he's like
South African yeah but they were just he
was just zoning in on the name no my
stomach just dropped
I didn't know what to say didn't know
what to think in the moment there my dad
was in the military and a buddy that you
know he was very close to served with
him and so when my dad was in the
military Khalil was killed and my dad
just named me after him one of his best
friends it was not about the money it
was never about the money it's about
shedding a light on an issue I feel very
passionate about I had to think like
what would Jesus do a [ __ ] makes me
sick dude you know the people who left
me that note
finds Jesus and you need to find Jesus
you lying sack of [ __ ]
hope that he can experience the love
that I've experienced from Jesus Christ
what's so [ __ ] shitty is that like
this guy [ __ ] it up for everybody else
that like this job people don't take
this [ __ ] seriously is because like
they're people like him that are like
making [ __ ] up I've never seen somebody
with every tooth that had a gap in it
really did you have jack-o'-lantern
teeth like every tooth has a gap Wow
does that make flossing easier order
[Music]
somebody's shark today dad that fool
flosses with toothpicks dude every time
he lies his gaps get wider imagine the
the entering he leaves when he bites
into an apple oh [ __ ] there's almost
like we know who did this it was coil
[ __ ] like this make it way harder way
harder for people to [ __ ] speak up
and when some [ __ ] really goes down they
go that's one of those fake fraud
minorities again talking you know he's a
really good liar though yeah it's kind
of like scary [ __ ] a psychopath
so he actually got about a thousand
dollars in donations from people that
felt sorry for him when why why did they
donate to him for what so he could buy
more grenades to support as terrorism
you know like every time there is
something that happens like like some
injustice there's always people that but
I don't get why they're giving him money
because he didn't get a tip is that what
almost wants braces maybe yeah [ __ ] this
boy is [ __ ] these can't have a good
meal is always getting corn stuck and
[ __ ] every time you talk he whistles
[Music]
that was like thousand dollars for
dental work that's what that's what it
was for no it's a knife for braces he's
saying that that money will be returned
and he is also no longer employed yeah
no [ __ ]
can he go to jail yeah a fake racism I
think you should man
I think you should've character at least
get a fine or something yeah then the
restaurant reached out to that customer
that be initially been bought three
steaks for life yeah every [ __ ]
stupid is [ __ ] like this actually
separates people so far then it creates
no [ __ ] trust and it's like God what
are you doing I wish this would have
happened to me they should they should
give him like a sentence where he has to
wear a turban for a year like if you
want to assume the identity of like this
race that's getting like persecuted you
should actually feel what they actually
have to feel oh so you just send them
through all the TSA s all the fun good
time what the [ __ ] tournament and like
[ __ ] your robes and sandals and you put
dirt on his feet and then just have like
a fake a K on them and have them walk
through all the airports like Rachel
Dolezal is that she's the black for the
n-double-a-cp right yeah if you want to
assume a certain identity so you can get
like these this pity like sympathy then
you have to go through the actual [ __ ]
and throw them in like middle of like
middle America did you guys hear about
that [ __ ] about Rachel Dolezal like she
went to jail for the welfare checks and
[ __ ] and dude I cracked up so hard
because of Twitter and like every black
person saying like yes you died let it
go she's like did the news do like a
follow up on this guy well this is the
fall of the fact that he lied oh because
this initially went viral over like oh
my god this sucks someone wrote that on
the receipt I mean how many other people
are doing this [ __ ] like that's what
gets me thinking like how many other
people are going out there crying wolf
you know it's like they can't trust
anybody it's like [ __ ] like this happen
yeah any when there's real racism that
needs to be you know called out and all
that [ __ ] then it should be some some
sort of repercussions yeah cuz that's
like that's like the the ladies that use
false rape to to get it like their
ex-boyfriends or somebody yeah yeah and
then it makes it harder for other women
to actually come forth and do stuff cuz
that no
right you should just lineup although
every single culture like should have a
slap ambassador right and we [ __ ] in we
get the and every race like the biggest
[ __ ] hat with the strongest [ __ ]
whip right and then when every time
somebody [ __ ] it up for all minorities
they just stand in a big [ __ ] line
and just hold every single day boom
every culture not today is China day
bomb
hello today it should be like everyone
from that culture to like this is like
you know I do tans gonna get tired no no
that it's one person from every [ __ ]
race no I think it should be like a
community kind of like a barbecue or
whatever like everyone comes over brings
everyone together so it's that so
whatever it is like that uh that like
whatever
I know whoever wants to come enjoy bring
your own slabs all right I want to make
it multicultural that's what brings us
together have you ever been slept before
huh have you ever slept before yeah my
mom Oh what did that feel like
what did you do oh I was talking back
and we were and he was so funny because
we were in TJ and every time we crossed
the border she's like no we're in Mexico
you can't it don't matter now I can
really reach him so when she would wait
till you across the border to hit you
know that's just the threat that they
threat but this one time though I really
did deserve a house being a wall and TJ
yeah I was in Tuesday I remember what I
said but I was just being a [ __ ] I go
the teenager you know talking back to my
mom and then all like my brain rattled a
little bit it came back with the British
accent no thank you for that mother Ivy
I got slap every single day as a kid
yeah never got slapped I did but like
like my mom you guys are my mom like
she's really soft so for her like a
crate like just the fact that she wets
even slap my face is already like so
against who she is so you could tell
that she like resisted a lot that me my
face was like my mom freaking water for
reals is like every single day how much
did you deserve and how much did you
down sir um it's hard to say I
I deserve the loksat's the batkid but
it's also hard to say when you don't
know what you did right you know it was
just like I'm just like maybe watching
TV but I'm like what the [ __ ] and I'm
like what did I do
just come out of nowhere figure it out I
think that makes you found it she'll
never she'll never tell me now you could
have been mouth breathing and she
smacked you because you weren't
breathing through your nose yeah like
I'm eating we're eating dinner and boom
and the [ __ ] chopsticks come hitting
in the hand or hit me in the face I'm
just like what the [ __ ] is going on hey
Dada I got sent this video the other day
I gotta send it to you guys but this
girl was like look I don't know what
country it was I couldn't get a language
but this mom beat the [ __ ] out of her
[ __ ] daughter she did something so
bad she literally started [ __ ] her up
and the heat she stripped her daughter
but Megan and put it on the middle of
the street like she's like arrest the
rock I don't know how old she was she
had to be like 18 17 or daughter the
daughter so the mom was well Oh cuz
she's sleeping around she's a full-grown
adult never seen it but that's the only
thing I can think that wasn't in this
country I think you want to be a [ __ ]
here that's what a [ __ ] does because of
the naked part yeah I originally thought
it was like two young girls fighting but
then I looked at I was like no that's a
mom and she was beating the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of her yeah that's probably what it
was stripped her butt-naked an adult
woman and threw her out the house and
grabbed her by the hair and dragged her
and the girl probably was just like
holding hands with a guy or something
were they Asian no they looked like
it'll even Middle Eastern or Mexican oh
wow it's hard to drive yeah it was a
really bad video but he was just like
y'all this shit's [ __ ] wild and he
said I was like yeah what the [ __ ] if it
is it's crazy dude I feel so bad for the
girl dude that's so sad violence doesn't
teach nothing to nobody
[Music]